the near boards and it comes through to Bo
Gru through the middle of the ice zel wiger
jumps up comes in takes a shot and that one
off the goal post well he could shoot it and
he can certainly get those wheels turning ol zel
wigger almost gives Anaheim the lead he's on his
off Wing gets a lot on that little snapshot
he had Ken and beaten over the glove on the
short side and the first Big Break Of The Game
Belongs to the Sharks Ruda throws it towards
the net that's blocked unable to get the handle
is Leo Carlson zerland keeps it alive gets it
back with a one timer and Gibson able to cover
it up an easy Escape for them and that's what
Burrows just did there leushin moves it up and
Here Come the Ducks on the rush McTavish into
the slot silverberg kind of fanned on it do a
good job on his dump in Anaheim with an easy
exit they had a three on two Rush kick it to
the wing Center Lane Drive and then the man's
open in the middle that was a good stop by
the goenda and you're not allowed to jam the
goenda that silverberg pushes the puck over this
isn't going to count they're going to look at it
ohuk back behind his own net blew a wheel and
loses the puck as he was pressured by McTavish
pass comes through to Mason right at the top
of the crease lundestrom scores Isaac has his
first of the year and the ducks have the lead all
about the pressure up ice on the four check I beg
your pardon it's his second of the season it's
been so good in the last three games and this is
the reason why McTavish got in on the four check
silverberg look at the patience McTavish keeps
it alive the Sharks don't pick up lond strowman
he gets inside of Anthony duclair and duclair
can't tie up his stick and watch him a quick move
backhand to forehand and he jams it at home three
goals four in each game and you can do that if
everybody gets more involved Sharks win the face
off shot off the right board sticks to John Gibson
but you want to establish that you're going to be
aggressive with him the ducks have done a good job
of doing that in this game LOL trying to chip it
to himself loses it at the Blue Line a great right
P save made by Gibson on kinan up top John Gibson
that was an outstanding save on Luke 22nd ranked
power play in the league sends it back in Jacob
McDonald hard around off the Stick of Carrick
and now it's recovered Muka Mulan gives it up
one times it fat rebound Gibson with a couple
of 10 Bell saves especially on Hoffman and now
it is in the net I thought he got the left pad on
the rebound but he was unable to cover the puck
and the sharks have tied the game yeah you know
what he just kind of lost his balance and when
the goenda but then Can't Get Back Square to the
puck you can see John's trying to scramble right
there but he could not and the rebound was just
kind of popped home I think it's Luke Hunan right
on the doorstep or does it go through or does it
go through underneath yeah and it kind of never T
touches it yep it's going to be Anthony duclair's
goal on the power play and It ultimately sneaks I
believe five ho and it doesn't touch the back of
the net but it's in trying to protect the puck
as stro was for checking from behind fer pushes
up the wall and now gets some help from Henrik
pops loose Leo Carlson got it right back little
two-man game was strowman a good save by kinen
strome feeds the point The Defenders are tired
zelger gallops through the slot fires and it's
loose in the skates of Henrik and he couldn't get
it back gives it up now Motion in the offensive
zone from the Sharks Addison got it through
Gibson didn't cover the rebound off the side
of the net as Addison did a drive by but people
aren't being moved out from in front of the net
you could see that rebound came and he was able
to protect that short side kayin Addison's going
to get a crack at this and John makes a real
good stop with that right leg pad Here Comes
Addison sneaking down from the left point you
see he just kind of kicks out that right foot
it's just enough long time between whistles
eight and 1 half gone second period still tied
at one here's a two-on-one for San Jose stur
Hoffman Hoffman shoots big save Gibson had to
be real careful there and then olens El wigger
got caught on a bad pinch had led to this two
onone Hoffman with the shot and he can shoot it
that's a real good stop by Gibson with the right
p played 44 of those games for the New Jersey
Devils I this a guy who can handle the workload
he's a big man 6'4 225 lbs classic does it
again a blast from the point and San Jose's
defense continues to get it done it's two one
shs yeah I heard that shot hit something similar
to the goal lassic scored last night against
the Seattle Kraken he's just hammering away
from distance what does it hit was it sadena
was it leushin pretty sure this Puck changes
direction oh maybe not bth of the season for David
Quinn yeah we haven't got a report as to whether
or not those players might be able to return
and as you pointed out earlier here's a chance
as Gibson makes the save not seen an indication
that there was going to be any penalty there's
a hit by gutus in the corner it was sterm I
beg your pardon niik sterm with a last minute
poke and five on five once again pass through the
middle of the ice Fowler able to find lundestrom
drops it off for McTavish band get the feet moving
as he receives that pass now into the slot off the
goal post from bakan Puck down low and he's going
to just throw on the brakes and then he's going to
spot right in the middle in that slot area was vak
in and a quick little wrist shot got it through
and Ken and beat another shot and it's been on
display here tonight Terry dangles right down
Main Street now wheels back with it 40 seconds
in the power play zelger finds Carl into the
middle redirected right on loose rebound and it's
Swept Away by con this is it shot a little bit
here's that high tip play I was talking about with
McTavish with a redirect Leo carries in separated
from the puck kept by silverberg Terry picks up
the Loose Change got it into the slot for Carrick
save kinen it's a great play by Troy Terry there's
three shark players thinks it out here comes Leo
Carlson right through the middle hands it off to
the Terry on right wing pulls it in and whips his
pass across zeliger keeps it in Fowler skates
it to the middle throws it to the net looking
for a redirect rebound is there digging for it
they score Troy Terry ties the game with 101
left well this is a big goal it's a point shot
that gets through that is redirect for kinan to
handle the rebound here's the entri wer does a
good job keeping that puck alive but there's a
tip right here and it's hen reek and it's Leo
Carlson that keeps it alive he knows exactly
where Troy Terry is and he just slides it across
it's got a wide open that a smart little play by
Carlson Mark Edward blasic almost stopped
that yeah you're right he almost made the
safe the big Russian snaps it ahead trying to
jump around here's duclair Swept Away by lome who
reached back Terry picks it up under a minute to
go in overtime two-on one with a tronto to prick
scor he's going to the allstar game a fans
going home with his stick and the Ducks are
going home with two points hockey of
the season and watch how he races to
get this Puck away from duclair and now
it's a two-on one young defenseman Mulan
back Terry waits for the perfect time as
saucers that pass over to for Toronto and